my name is Barry bass and welcome to the
problem is my voice is all what the hell
happened there I'm sorry but there's
nothing we didn't do I know Excalibur a
doll a lady we can have babies instead
oh wait never mind
all right let's go still purple what
what all right [ __ ] you sign trying to
tell me to [ __ ] up I mean keep out
whatever all right here we go and that's
your own sign company well across lines
man never meant to cross that's a lot of
nice crosses got some science stuff in
the back time travel radioactive bath
battalion would be radioactive job damn
you radio art I bounce now sit nice on
you I give you that barrels all right
clicking this time machine should take
me back to I don't dynastar time that's
my favorite time [ __ ] love dinosaurs
not to be racist or anything I'm sorry
that offends anyone all right here we go
whoa oh my god I'm trippin boss
let's go oh no it's a dinosaur time that
I was talking about Taschen time oh my
god Stegosaurus Oh Oh did this do you
know did this do you
I'll get him sweating ow [ __ ]
Jennifer alright whatever
thank you God thank God do you found me
I've been in this era ah [ __ ] scary
[ __ ] man the hell is he doing to him
see fapping now okay how dinosaurs can't
pop for candy we will never know all
right what a journey
oh no don't crack the eggs Oh back in
the cave
back in the cave all right I'm lucky I'm
alive
it's a miracle whoa bouncy watch it man
fossils in Batangas sorry I guess that
makes no sense but whatever all right
jump to tree line here no no no it's too
good to be true I will ride I will write
oh my god I just got to get up here all
right
eject Zed then immediately hold up all
right all right I'm gonna call your
birthday I'm humping your back uh why
don't you don't stop when I'm humping
you Jesus Christ [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] yeah I
feel good oh yeah
come on back to our let's finish this
together
ah I get [ __ ] by the leg instead that
was an epic man really cool really fun
all right jet well don't [ __ ] with me
jet wad I hope you like it
sorry well if I can play level 1 all
right come on I suck at these yeah I
know I just said it one second ago just
spicy little [ __ ] all right what the
[ __ ] level can we do okay okay you gotta
do okay yeah well since when did you
became a cocky little dad that's what
you get for disrespecting me what the
[ __ ] what I want to see this [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] ill me see I'm sorry I don't
really like those type of man like glass
breaks and nothing kind of the same [ __ ]
if you ask me but whatever
alright then to jump alright let's go
guys I am and I double front up denied
front but take your [ __ ] out of my
[ __ ] bye why droplet [ __ ] awesome
alright must be front flip and with
finish data don't touch my ass huh
there's a matter of car doors - Jim
Bonacci free thoughts
who will ride jingle Bonacci huh I guess
grandpa let's go I take we go damn take
me why not gem is there something you
wanna call right here
Jim I got your nipples yeah tell me why
don't you love me Jim
tell me yeah goddamn you Jim why don't
you love me I don't get it
save your dad that's a pretty day pretty
legit oh no it's got a Caliphate Gaza
[ __ ] yeah alright see you later [ __ ]
just you and me Mike
now let's hike have sexual intercourse
together
why are you that doesn't even make sense
alright see what this is about
I'm so sad I don't have any football
wait a second what is this well you came
back to me I love you ball let's make
love this is not supposed to happen
okay let's do it seriously go no don't
follow I know I'm fat you know that does
not mean I should [ __ ] all right another
one let's go down here let's go down
here
grab that [ __ ] oh that's how I get the
ladies hold down all right yeah let's go
I'm gonna climb these walls yep I knew
it I knew it you know this acted kind of
cool that's amazing let's climb tomorrow
shall we yeah no way we're switcheroo
I love switcher alright and now the
grand finale wall with the backflip
double front okay will probably not be
anything like that ah that was just an
exit pretty cool I guess
Mountain survival that sounds like my
type of map to be honest Santa Claus is
gonna fire the mountain
let's go melon [ __ ] you it's you and me
melon oh hey Matt how you did see you
like melon come back to me melis ah
melon head but is stopped but the puck
is gonna don't you dare see my head that
is not really good plan I think Sunday's
to fight for that one someone who is
alright this guy I never I feel like
what the [ __ ] come on let's go with the
fatty then the big fat titties oh the
big a love Marilyn a LeBaron alright
good for you let's go mallet Melly oh no
I think my kids fell out
god damn it I'm a meatball now I'm a
real meat box
where's melon why is that [ __ ] I want
to finish it with melon alright [ __ ]
it's the only man who can alright I'll
show you [ __ ] how it's done
melon I [ __ ] love you oh wow yeah
alright dad am i doing a barter what
haha all right about here I'm not eating
any one's penis genitals ah still alive
well let's drive going to alright this
should work all right now that melly-mel
a
tablet humping tablet come on wait a
melon gap ah [ __ ]
that [ __ ] is [ __ ] awesome Acrobat my
body reassembled oh I got a new pair of
pants
ha I wish there was one guy who can
stand up to the crowd Pogo man you're up
for the challenge man oh maybe this guy
come on stop [ __ ]
alright alright merely ledge gal I
protect you in my back home now right am
i late don't worry Molly I'll protect ya
malee so many ah can't even see my heart
stayed in my heart will not go on
alright that's how the [ __ ] am I
supposed to set than this ah
alright ever stop complaining man let's
ride this guy what what riding cars like
a bass I always loved tie my ass in the
air when I ride my car
sorry about that lady sorry about that
just got a ride my car
god damn I love you can't you ride a car
without a lady getting it [ __ ] spear
to watch it I'm still like another sack
actually like this like I kind of like
it I like oh even better position
that's alright here we go
jump over them I don't want to kill any
innocent people don't want to kill
anyone who thought about that lady
[ __ ] happens deal with it alright
everybody who's that gay people right no
oh nice front flip ending
nice front fit alright a pyro inspired
Matt let's try nothing oh it's the power
line alright it's kind of gay that's
okay
shouldn't there be a pirate or some [ __ ]
alright we got a present than [ __ ] okay
that's nice I love presents
whoa what the [ __ ] well what no way
good for you huh huh no ah it broke that
doesn't matter if it breaks or not
that's not department and bike we'll
keep riding to this day [ __ ]
alright I think that's enough happy
wheels manners for one episode thank you
bro so much brothers report I'm really
loving making these videos it's so much
fun for me yeah trust me but anyway like
a parent enjoyed subscribe to come
Brisbane I'll see you next episode of I
make
I